es passierte während eines autorennens
am wochenende in der ungarischen stadt
topcom los bei der traditionellen
stadtrallye verlor der fahrer des roten
rennwagens die kontrolle über sein
fahrzeug und raste in eine gruppe von
zuschauern
nach angaben von lokalen medien wurden
bei dem vorfall mindestens elf menschen
verletzt zwei von ihnen wurden mit dem
hubschrauber ins krankenhaus gebracht
ihr zustand soll kritisch sein
den berichten zufolge untersuchen die
behörden wie es zu dem unfall kommen
konnte und ob es möglicherweise
sicherheitsmängel gegeben habe in diesem
jahr fand das rennen zum zehnten mal
statt mehr als 100 fahrer waren am start